in the aftermath of an eu economic
crisis and a weakened nato alliance the
world powers are faced with an
increasingly militarily powerful north
korea led by kim jong-un that appears to
have partnered up with a nationalist
russian government in an attempt to
salvage the chaotic situation worldwide
the u.s has sent most of its troops out
leaving american structures back home
open to all forms of attack including
cyber attacks from enemy countries the
movie opens with a high school football
match in spokane washington that
features maddie eckert as one of the
players maddie's team the wolverines are
playing against a visiting team the
titans as the game rages on maddie's
girlfriend a cheerleader named erica
makes an appearance maddie's dad police
sergeant tom eckert watches from the
sidelines and he is soon joined by his
other son jed eckert a u.s marine who
has recently returned home after the
game jed leaves and heads to a nearby
bar to get a drink there he is
approached by tony walsh a childhood
acquaintance who clearly has a crush on
him as tony and jed hit it off maddie
and erica arrive at the bar however
their stay at the bar is short-lived
because moments later an unexpected
blackout leads to everyone going home
back at home tom heads out to attend his
night shift leaving his two sons home
alone before they go to bed a
conversation between the brothers
reveals that their relationship is
strained the next morning jed and mati
are awoken by the commotion outside when
they step out of the house they are
shocked to witness several north korean
paratroopers and transport aircrafts
hovering in the sky instinctively the
pair get into jed's truck and head out
in search of their father after
overcoming numerous obstacles and
driving through fire they locate tom who
instructs them to go to the family's
cabin in the woods while he stays behind
to help the people all around the
father-son trio people are being shot
and taken captive by the invading north
koreans who are under the leadership of
commander cho following their father's
instructions jed and maddie start
driving to the cabin but first they take
a detour to save erica on reaching
erica's house they learned that she and
her family have already been captured as
jed and maddie drive away maddie's
friends robert and daryl emerge from a
nearby house and jump into the back of
the truck as it is the only way to
escape capture appearing to be the only
ones who know what to do jed and maddie
soon gain a following consisting of two
other cars however after a head-on
collision with commander cho who refuses
to let them go without a fight only two
of the vehicles make it to the cabin at
the cabin jed maddie robert and daryl
get acquainted with pete and siblings
greg and julie the occupants of the
second car later that day they are
joined by tony and danny another friend
of maddie's bringing the total number of
escapees to nine immediately jed takes
control of the situation and assigns
roles to everyone in a matter of hours
the group has managed to gather all
available supplies set up electricity
and put together all available weapons
in preparation for what is to come
around nightfall pete and jed have a
confrontation after pete carelessly
fires a gun and this marks the beginning
of bad blood between them the following
day the other runaways learn that pete
took the confrontation to heart and has
run away with all the food supplies what
a greedy [ __ ] despite this the group
stays put while jed and maddie head back
into the city to survey the area there
the brothers discover that prison units
have been created and several americans
including erica have been arrested later
that day when maddie and jed return to
the woods they are met by the others who
inform them that pete has led commander
cho and the north koreans to the cabin
as a ploy to draw out the runaways
commander cho has brought along with him
daryl's father mayor jenkins along with
tom using a megaphone mayor jenkins
renders a convincing speech and pleads
with his son and the others to surrender
but they refuse on the contrary when the
megaphone is given to tom he urges his
sons and the rest of the group to keep
fighting sadly this heroic act earns the
father of two a gunshot in the head
courtesy of commander cho much to the
dismay of his sons they somehow managed
to stay hidden despite being invisible
agony fueled by rage brought about by
the individual losses they have suffered
and inspired by a heartfelt speech from
jed the teenagers make a decision they
decide to stick with jed and fight
against the people who have invaded
their home once this unanimous decision
is reached jed assumes the position of
captain and he begins to prepare the
seven for the task ahead through
rigorous training when the need arises
the team enlists the help of allies on
the outside to gain access to food
supplies and information satisfied with
their training the group sets out on
their first assignment which is to steal
weapons and ammunition from the north
korean soldiers using tony as bait the
team is able to lure some of the
invading soldiers to a secluded area
where they launch a successful ambush
with the soldiers dead the rebels grab
all their weapons and bulletproof vests
with these weapons they launch another
attack on some nearby soldiers and
successfully take them down teen
american footballers taking down an
advanced organized militia
this is my kind of story baby after this
they ransacked the military vehicle the
soldiers had been guarding and escape
with all its contents including
explosives after reaching their hideout
the members of the group start bonding
and are getting more comfortable with
fending for themselves in the wild
through it all maddie misses erika
terribly and he looks at a picture of
them together before bed when the day
breaks jet and the rebels coordinate a
large-scale attack against the north
koreans using the explosives and weapons
they had taken earlier the attack
consists of several calculated
explosions in different north korean
army bases after each attack the team
who have taken on the name wolverines
leaves a graffiti design on a nearby
wall claiming responsibility for their
actions and inspiring hope in the hearts
of american onlookers at the site where
one of the explosions is set to happen
jed danny and maddie catch sight of pete
who has accepted a position as a
collaborator in the north korean forces
eventually pete dies in the explosion
but not before maddie flips him the
goddamn bird satisfied with the success
of their mission the wolverines initiate
their escape plan back at their new
hideout in an abandoned mine the eight
discuss what they miss most from the
days when things were normal when it is
maddie's turn he remains silent but he's
thinking booty and shortly after he
heads back to the city on his own in the
city he watches the prison from a
distance hoping to see erica which he
eventually does when mattie returns at
night he meets an angry jed waiting for
him outside soon an argument ensues
between the two with jed accusing maddie
of endangering the team and maddie
pointing out that erica is more family
to him than jed when things get heated
jed shoves maddie however instead of
fighting back maddie tosses his phone to
the ground claiming it contains
information on how to get to cho before
walking away on the phone is information
about a rally cho will be attending in
main square immediately jed comes up
with a plan to get cho while he is on
stage according to the plan a car bomb
near the location would serve as a decoy
and amidst all the chaos brought about
by the first bomb the second one would
go off under the stage killing cho and
his allies on the spot what's the point
of the decoy in the next scene d-day
comes and as the rally begins in full
swing the wolverines who are positioned
all around the venue initiate the plan
beginning with the car bomb 90 seconds
before the first explosion daryl spots
his father on stage with cho while this
is a hard pill for him to swallow the
teenager does not back down
instead he gives the go-ahead for the
show to commence less than a minute
before the explosion occurs maddie
catches sight of a bus conveying
prisoners nearby when he spots erika
inside he completely loses focus and
demands that julie blow up the car even
though it is not time yet eventually he
gets his way and after the explosion he
chases after the bus with erica in it
while trying to get the situation back
under control jed looks out of a window
amidst all of the commotion and locks
eyes with commander cho who seems to
have anticipated their attack from the
stage he gives a command to his men and
immediately jed and the other wolverines
are under fire while jed and the rest of
the team are attempting to escape maddie
is on a solo mission to rescue erica on
the bus matty and erica have an
emotional reunion but when he tries to
escape with her he realizes that she is
chained to the seat outside the rest of
the team have escaped the building and
are desperately calling out to maddie
but he doesn't notice them left with no
choice greg starts walking towards the
bus hoping to get maddie's attention but
sadly he never makes it as the north
koreans gun him down with greg dead the
soldiers hot on their heels and maddie
being adamant about saving erica the
remaining six members of the team
initiate their escape plan leaving
maddie behind meanwhile on the bus
maddie somehow finds the keys and frees
erica from the chains as the rest of the
team escapes through a tube and drives
away in a stolen vehicle matty and erica
get off the bus unfortunately they are
immediately pursued by several officers
luckily they managed to escape with the
help of a clothing store owner the pair
comes out of the shop looking slightly
different and the officers don't seem to
recognize them anymore outside tony sees
erica and maddie approaching and is
elated to see erica safe as maddie makes
for the entrance jet emerges from inside
and breaks the news of greg's death
insinuating that maddie's decision to go
solo cost greg his life later that night
erica tells the team that the russians
have gotten involved and the invaders
have compiled a list of all their allies
in response jed and the others declare
their intentions to protect as many of
their contacts as possible the next day
the shop owner who helped matty and
erica is brought before some north
korean officers and is sentenced to
death for helping the wolverines however
before the execution can take place the
wolverines interrupt by opening fire on
the officers from several vantage points
after winning the gunfight the
wolverines celebrate by chanting their
name aloud and some members of the
general public join in on the chant
signifying that the group has gained
quite a following this development is
perceived as a threat by the north
korean military because the rebels
appear to be gaining momentum because of
this commander cho receives orders to
handle the situation immediately
meanwhile in the wolverine's camp matty
struggles to accept what happened to
greg so he isolates himself when three
days pass and he has still not come
around jed heads out in search of him
when they come face to face the two
brothers have an emotional conversation
that helps them unpack some issues from
the past that evening maddie returns to
the mine later that night tony and jed
who are hanging out by the lake are just
about to share a kiss when they realize
that the mine is being attacked as a
result they immediately hurry back in
the mine amidst all the confusion jed
directs his team members to make a run
sadly danny and julie fail to make it
out alive together the six survivors
retreat deeper into the woods to evade
capture there they come across marine
sergeant major andrew tanner and his
companions corporal smith and sergeant
hodges with a name like tanner this
dude's sure to beat some ass after
establishing that they are on the same
side andrew and his men give the
wolverines a situation report on how the
rest of the country is faring they then
reveal that they have a plan to steal a
suitcase containing an emp-resistant
radio telephone from the north koreans
and enlist the help of the wolverines in
the hands of the us forces the device
would be an effective tool for spying on
the invaders and would ultimately give
them an edge in the fight since the
device is always in commander cho's
custody the team now consisting of four
marines and five teenagers have to
infiltrate the local police station to
retrieve it the team then proceeds on
their mission but unfortunately unknown
to daryl he is tagged with a tracking
device by russian soldiers as a result a
firefight breaks out between the rebels
and the north koreans leaving hodges one
of the marines dead after they managed
to steal the box from the north koreans
maddie escapes with it while jed who is
injured stays behind to fight cho in the
end jed shoots and kills cho with a gun
he finds in his dad's former locker
following this with no one left to stand
in their way the group members head to a
safe house to plan their next move and
celebrate their small victory in the
house jed tells maddie that he is proud
of him and then has an intimate
conversation with tony sadly things
quickly go south as jed is unexpectedly
killed in a russian ambush despite being
visibly shaken by jed's death matty and
the rest escape from the house and start
making their way to the marines
extraction point where a uh-1 aircraft
is waiting on the way robert figures out
that daryl has been tagged with a
tracker which is how the russians were
able to locate them left with no other
choice the group members say an
emotional farewell to daryl and leave
him behind at the marine extraction
point sergeant andrew tries to convince
maddie and the remaining wolverines to
leave with them but they respectfully
decline choosing to stay back and fight
a brave move to be sure but also dumb as
hell the movie ends with maddie who is
now leading the resistance delivering
the same speech that jed gave when it
all began to a large group of newly
recruited rebels subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching